et dominic leblanc rezlus vous
l'entendiez tout à l'heure dans
beauséjour il est avec nous sur le blanc
d'abord félicitations et merci beaucoup
mais seulement sur le blanc dites moi
vraiment vous ne vous attendiez quand
même pas un aussi bon score 1-1
atlantique
non moi je pensais qu'on allait très
bien faire moi je pensais qu'on avait
des très bonnes chances dans plusieurs
circonscriptions à travers l'atlantique
mais l'idée qu'on peut peut-être
possiblement prendre toute les comptes
et en atlantique pas je pense pas qu'on
ont même ont rêvé d'avoir une un appui
aussi important vous êtes en voie
monsieur leblanc d'avoir plus 20
circonscriptions l'atlantique donc comme
vous dites
les trente 30 2 sur 32 à quoi vous
attribuez ça est-ce que c'est quand vous
faisiez la votre porte par porte quand
vous parlez aux gens c'est vraiment le
désir de changement pour vous avez vu
comme étant plus du côté du pouvoir
il n'y a pas de doute que justin trudeau
résonner très très bien l'atlantique les
gens en acadie par exemple dans ma
circonscription dans d'autres
circonscriptions francophones de
l'atlantique ont immédiatement réagi
d'une façon très positive à la campagne
de justin trudeau
il est connu en acadie l'été mais en
acadie à ça c'était un avantage mais
aussi dans d'autres régions peut-être
pas les régions francophones de
l'atlantique
la plateforme libérale qui avançaient
l'idée d'investir massivement pour créer
des emplois de travailler avec les
gouvernements provinciaux qui se donne
des gouvernements
béraud en atlantique était pour nous une
chose très importants et moi je pense le
fait que monsieur trudeau a mené une
campagne positive nous a beaucoup aidés
aussi a pas de tradition de campagne
négative en atlantique la façon que
monsieur rap et même monsieur mulcair
ont tenté de faire pendant certaines
périodes
mais comment vous expliquer je voulais
c'est là dessus comment vous expliquer à
ce point la dégringolade du npd aussi
qui n'a pas réussi à garder des endroits
où quand même vous avez des racines
moi je pense pas que les gens ont vu
dans la plateforme de monsieur mulcair
où le discours de monsieur mulcair
l'alternatif progressistes en europe
que ce soit sur les avions de chasse
furtifs et non pas la construction
navale halifax haïti il était dans le
même temps même politique que monsieur
rappaz en ce qui a trait aux avions de
chasse en ce qui a trait à pas de
déficit pour stimuler l'économie
à c moi je pense dans beaucoup de cas
les gens ont vu monsieur mulcair hésité
de vraiment prendre la voie progressiste
et justin trudeau a mené une campagne
très petit j'imagine nous avait hâte
comme nous d'avoir les résultats du
québec c'est dans 25 minutes
québec ontario le reste du pays mais
c'est ça moi je vais quitter shediac peu
de ton et chez moi le plus vite passé
pour les regarder
moi même j'ai allumé votre téléphone et
la salut merci au revoir